l'histoire racontée par des chaussettes
c'est très marrant en 1777 joseph ii
d'autriche rend visite à son beau frère
à son beauf comme disent les jeunes
louis saez rois de france parce que lui
et marie-antoinette ont pas encore eu
d'enfant
alors ils se demandent que peut-être il
se passe des fins on sait pas trop on
comprend pas on a il se pose vraiment
vous dise et c'est ce que nous allons
vous raconter dans cet épisode
j'espère qu'il va pas me demander de
discuter c'est tout bon louis il faut
qu'on discute en dieu pas qu'on a et la
chasse un peu hein on chasse un peu on
discute un peu non non non
là c'est important faut qu'on discute tu
peux pas d'esquiver tout le temps 10 ans
va à la chasse aux vaches
d'accord c'est une question délicate un
masseur et toi vous êtes mariés depuis
un bon moment déjà d'accord et pourtant
pas d'héritier oui pourquoi
d'accord ben oui non je vais poser des
questions simples
ma soeur à rennes autrichienne facile on
va à la chasse non au lycée enfin si
autrichienne oui mais c'est pas ça en
gros vous êtes un petit couple toi et ma
soeur mais qu'est ce qu'ils font les
petits couples y mange ensemble
ils partagent des passions discute qui
vont la chasse ouais j'y ai aussi ils
partagent le même lit
et c'est à ce niveau là que il ya un
problème parce que la reine ma soeur
elle est venue me voir pour me dire
joseph nada joseph c'est moi mais
c'était pour être sue et ça c'est bon
elle m'a dit avec louis nadal pourquoi
elle t'a par l'espagnol et
l'autrichienne
non mais change pas de sujet on était
dans un sujet oui bon louis il faut que
tu te concentres d'accord t'es prêt
comtesse de bad le jour un nouveau jeu
voilà qu'est ce que ça t'inspire ça hein
mon pâtissier
non ce n'est pas sale si le rire
bon d'accord je vais utiliser des
références à toi qu'est ce que tu aimes
bien dans la vie l'achat par la chasse
les serrures quan ho ho mais ok d'accord
alors la reine elle a une serrure
spécial l'aco qui l'ex elle a trouvé la
crau qu'il est que je vais aller la voir
je lui donne la bretagne la crau qui
l'ex s'est fait non c'est pas ça t'as
rien compris
alors dit le truc que tu veux dire
depuis c'est pourquoi vous couchez pas
ensemble hun sen et ça c'est parce que
j'ai un problème physiologique à vas-y
montre ballon c'est gai mais s'est
montrée au nom entre nous non
mais on est de la même famille n'ont pas
jupe tube n'ont qu'à les noms aller non
pour guérir non aller non mais non allez
ok mais c'est rien ça ça tu te fait
circoncire c'est bon seul au hockey et
c'est ainsi que la descendance des
bourbons fut assurée tout cas d'après
des chaussettes moufia